- [Narrator] For over 200 million years
these creatures have roamed the Earth,
but now their future is uncertain.
This is the American horseshoe crab.
Found along the Atlantic
coastline of North America,
the American horseshoe crab
spends the majority of its time
in shallow waters but
comes to shore to mate.
The crab has 10 eyes,
the two most obvious ones
are on the top of its shell
but the others are on the
tail and near the mouth.
Horseshoe crabs are
harvested for their blood
which has helped prevent
illnesses across the globe;
but with the development
of their natural habitat
and over-harvesting,
this once abundant animal
has now seen such a
rapid decline in numbers
that they are considered
a vulnerable species.
This is the American horseshoe crab.